los sondeos a pie de urna ubican en
buena posición al este Primer Ministro
Benjamin netaniacu Para volver a
gobernar en Israel estas tres cifras se
difundidas por las principales cadenas
israelíes le otorgan a él y sus aliados
entre 61 y 62 escaños de los 120
disponibles en la quenet logrando así
una exigua mayoría que le permitiría
Volver al cargo de Primer Ministro y
extender su leyenda es como el más
longevo en el cargo su partido licudo
lograría entre 30 y 31 escaños siempre
de acuerdo a estos sondeos y se
sostendría esta Alianza principalmente
en el ascenso de la extrema derecha
consionismo religioso que lograría entre
14 y 15 escaños la otra pata de la
alianza son los partidos Ultra ortodoxos
que le permitirían entonces a netania
gobernar pero hay que tomar con cautela
estas cifras porque no siempre en el
pasado las encuestas a pie de urnas han
sido acertadas en Mostrar las fotos
final de la elección el recuento será
largo avanzará durante la noche y se
esperan que cifras oficiales más
consolidadas se trabajan durante el
miércoles o incluso el jueves los
primeros indicios positivos para
netanear con la jornada llegaron con la
participación alta la más alta desde
1999 lo cual sorprende un poco por la
apatía que generaba entre los israelíes
tener que acudir a las urnas por quinta
vez en menos de cuatro años esa apatía
sí se mostró mucho más fuerte entre La
minoría árabe desilusionada por falta de
respuestas del gobierno de Jake lapid lo
cual representa también de manera
indirecta una ganancia para las opciones
de netania Agus Más allá de que de lo
que determinen resultando los resultados
oficiales lo que ya se vislumbra es una
que necesita mucho más extremista y con
posiciones más derechistas la que saldrá
de estas elecciones